I had an experience with Cheryl and I
can't remember I was thinking it was on
beacon but it had it was a year later
than because explain what beacon is so
because at a seminal moment in the
history of this vegan was a product that
they created that was designed to
improve ad targeting and the basic
notion was they wanted to go to
advertisers and say oh really took two
people who did retail and say when
somebody buys something from you in the
physical world if they're on Facebook we
will post what they bought and create a
virtuous cycle that will draw traffic to
you and justify your doing advertising
on Facebook so you'll pay something to
have this thing happen to be a form of
advertising and right away like they
introduced this thing without any
preparation of the user base at all and
I don't know if it was the first day but
within a few days some poor guy buys an
engagement ring on overstock and it's
published on Facebook before he's even
spoken to his bride-to-be and so she
finds out he's gonna propose on
overstock I mean on Facebook with this
picture of the ring from overstock and
the price which was deeply discounted
and everyone they know finds out
simultaneously before he's been able to
tell anybody it was a Stan break thing
including that marriage forever forever
and so the blowback was staggering
within a few months they're forced to
show people found out that I was
listening to Steely Dan and this was
kind of brutal on my reputation was I
will joke I'm just raised as you in my
estimate so we connected Spotify - yeah
and I was like how do I turn this off I
remember talking to like Daniel and
other people to mauve and it's just like
I don't want people to see that I'm
listening to the same Dylan album you
know for 48 hours right that's what I do
with Dylan albums altiplano tracks what
the hell's on you know maybe listen to
infidels for three days you and me both
so so long story short that was one of a
series of situations where Marc pushed
the envelope on privacy without getting
approval ahead of time and it was the
most egregious to that point